I just want to bring you the latest
pictures from Paris where of course
we've been telling you that there have
been protests this evening after French
president Emmanuel macron used a special
procedure to push through controversial
Bill to raise the retirement age look at
those pictures on your screen now um
professors seem to have set fire to
um oh cars there that looks like tear
gas is being used on the streets of
Paris as well of course we've seen that
before
um for a lot of protesters on the
streets of Paris there the move of
course triggered process within
Parliament too with some politicians
singing the fresh National national
anthem holding placards saying no to 64
years today and the government is
arguing the retirement age must go up to
make sure the pension system doesn't go
thus the measure was has caused
widespread process over recent months
and tonight these scenes the very latest
from Paris you can see that is Place de
la Concorde with the needle there for
from Egypt in the middle police sir
they're in riot gear with water cannon
they seem to be charging towards
protesters and we saw on the streets of
Paris their protesters battling the
police um battling them as they fire
tear gas at them setting fire to what
looked like a car I couldn't really
quite tell what they'd set fire to but
and clearly hundreds of police officers
and protesters on the streets of Paris
tonight